hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
um November 7th 2022 what's going on how
why yeah
it's uh Sunday afternoon I'm about to do
I'm in whisk Madison Wisconsin
if you've never been here an absolutely
amazing college town
this is one of these colleges that makes
me wish I studied in high school
you know makes me wish I applied myself
and got student loans and lived at
school
and got one of these off-campus
apartments with the porch and the giant
couch in the front
and get [ __ ] hammered
right in major in dentistry or whatever
the [ __ ] would have happened
but I didn't
I didn't
uh but I could walk around the campus
now like an old creep
I actually am
I [ __ ] I'm fighting off a cold here
by the way
um
I went I'm working with Nate Craig
who's from the area uh who's been
absolutely [ __ ] destroying
um if you'd like to see
a guy before he sells a bunch of you
know theaters or whatever
go out and go see Nate Craig just Nate
Craig just Top Notch comedy
uh
I mean I was sitting there watching him
when we were in Grand Rapids I'm like
this guy is a he's a he's [ __ ] kill
he's a beast so definitely check him out
um half the places where I'm playing at
he's saying to people hey catch me when
I'm back in a couple of months so he's
out there doing the thing shout out to
him and he grew up in this area and took
me to this place
on the campus to get a Midwest
vanilla shake that's a malt
and uh you know I've been hitting the
gym when I've been out here
and also you know been substance free
until today I had a cup of coffee
if only had a cup of coffee it was
hilarious I went to this place uh
I want to say 30 for 30 but that's the
ESPN it's a coffee place in Peoria
Illinois
I was in Peoria Illinois what's that
that's a city can't say what he said
after that the Great Richard Pryor
uh one of my favorite heckles and
comebacks ever
stayed in character and kept going
um birthplace of Richard Pryor
which I'll get to that in a second I
went out and I got this coffee
got a cappuccino
and um
dude how about these guys that [ __ ]
parachute into a goddamn football
stadium like how do you even practice
for that
my God which is usually like in a
downtown area
there's all kinds of like skyscrapers so
you got venturi's and all of that [ __ ]
anything can blow you off course
ugh
it's inevitable
someday somebody's shoot isn't gonna
[ __ ] open and they're gonna bounce
right on the logo
the NFL will have a moment of silence
for five seconds spray paint the body
pink and they'll
stick it in that [ __ ] tent on the
sideline and the show Will Go On
um
so anyway I went to get this cup of
coffee
um by the way right now I'm currently
watching the Rams versus Tampa I bet the
Rams
because I just overheard that the uh
Tampa's uh
offensive line was banged up
so I was thinking like all right they
got that lunatic
whatever the [ __ ] his name
that uh
throwback 1960s NFL quarterback I mean
uh down lineman on the defense defensive
tackle so I'm like all right he should
be
you know
presenting some problems and it's just
not happening dude gambling's the
funniest [ __ ] [ __ ] ever
you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] catch the [ __ ]
ball
Jesus Christ
what the [ __ ] was that
what in the [ __ ] was that wide open
what the [ __ ] was that
it was just one of these track stars
they make a [ __ ] wide receiver
7 10 in the first quarter if you're
wondering
um I'm sure he's a good player
Jesus Christ ah [ __ ] Arizona's
winning I'm gonna go over and forth come
on Pete Carroll you sneaky bastard get
it covered just cover for me
um anyway
uh
I remember what I was talking about all
right so I was getting this goddamn
coffee right
and uh my first coffee in like a week or
so right no I had I had a double
espresso
on the way up whatever I've been doing
great you know I had two cups this week
doesn't have a hold of me
all right out of control uh
I [ __ ] uh I get a cappuccino
this lady put a swan
in in the milk I've never seen anybody
do a swan that was a new one and it was
a swan she even outlined the feathers
she was a master right
so unfortunately I was oh great great
[ __ ] protection great [ __ ]
protection Jesus Christ I'm gonna I'm
gonna go on for this week
you know what's funny though people
always you know why do you watch sports
it's so [ __ ] stupid it's like is it
it's one of the few things you can watch
where if you're the best at what you do
they don't give a [ __ ] what race you are
you actually get the job so there's one
for sports
foreign
[Laughter]
movies they're all [ __ ] white looks
like goddamn the MLB in the 1920s [ __ ]
are you giving me [ __ ] for
um
anyway
just imagine if we did all in this in
all of society
you know what I mean like how much
better did Sports get when they let
every race compete just think of all the
[ __ ] scientists all the [ __ ]
mathematicians and all of this stuff
these [ __ ] idiots this is another one
of these white guy [ __ ] elections
we're gonna take the country back
you know you know I'm a simple guy like
every other election they have the white
guy I'm a simple guy standing out in a
corn field or in the woods whittling
some [ __ ] wood when a guy says I'm a
simple guy that means he thinks he's
smarter than you
and just this whole [ __ ] idea that
he's gonna get in office and he has a
red tie and instead of a blue tie that
he's not also going to get bent over a
rail and [ __ ] in the ass by the
bankers it's hilarious to me
and the fact that the big bad Boogeyman
keeping us all down is some [ __ ] nerd
in a suit
dude there's no way I'm winning this
game Jesus Christ look at the size of
that guy starting the [ __ ] lawnmower
look at that guy
that's [ __ ] hilarious he just started
a lawnmower and it was a push mower not
even a ride mower I don't know who that
guy is he just became my famous [ __ ]
defensive lineman in the league number
50. shout out to him
look at that guy
I like how tight his jersey is too I
think that's Brave that he does that you
know like what a woman's in her third
trimester and she's wearing a
form-fitting dress they're like that's
so brave I think he's Brave to go out
there
to go out there like that
um
anyway
yeah I'm just a simple guy you know and
then so now we're gonna go all red right
on this election you can feel it it's
gonna happen and then we're going to end
up in the same [ __ ] situation and
then next midterm elections
Trump will be back and then we'll have
we'll have and everyone's gonna go blue
and it's going to be a bunch of [ __ ]
crying liberals like oh my God they're
not helping out the seals
right
and they're gonna [ __ ] everybody's
gonna run back this is what I don't
understand
am I really to believe like I don't get
like
how Donald Trump wins in 2016. tell me
with the math on this you know I'm just
a simple guy doing a podcast just
hitting here whittling on on a speaker
cord
sitting in a podcast Studio I'm just
like you you know I put my podcast pants
on one-legged attack
um
explain to me how all these
[ __ ] vote for Donald Trump
and he wins
right and they all [ __ ] love them
and then four years later he gets his
[ __ ] ass kicked
in the election right he did didn't it
wasn't I don't know what the [ __ ] the
numbers were I'm just saying he loses
so like what did a bunch of red people
go like well he's got it he's all right
ordered a bunch of blue people show up
who didn't [ __ ] show up the last time
and then the same thing with the midterm
elections right going all blue let's get
these [ __ ] red tie guys out of there
where are all the red people to be like
oh no you don't
right
so now it's gonna
it's all going to go the other I just
don't [ __ ] buy it
nobody in four years switches a party
everybody [ __ ] knows who they're
voting for everybody already [ __ ]
knows
none of it makes sense
it makes as much sense as what they're
doing now where they're going like
you're not counting the votes unless our
guy wins like that whole [ __ ] idea
no I don't none of it makes sense you
know and then people go why do you watch
sports
why don't you pick a side
uh
you know how much fun this country would
be if Bernie Sanders became president
and they actually worked with them all
of these [ __ ] [ __ ]
in the [ __ ] Democratic party who the
guy wins the nomination and they don't
let him [ __ ] run
then they have Hillary Clinton looking
like some old real estate agent runs
do you know how [ __ ] amazing those
debates would have been that's like when
you were waiting for Manny Pacquiao in
[ __ ] Mayweather to fight and by the
time they did they were it was just too
old right
oh my God Bernie's saying I was saying
Bernie would win but that would have
been so much more interesting
the two wild cards
you know we don't know what's gonna
happen
um
I'm gonna be talking politics here uh
like I think the uh the stupidest [ __ ]
in the [ __ ] world is after the
Democrats and Republicans pick
you know the stupid ass [ __ ] [ __ ]
that they're gonna have
you know be the next president the fact
that they then have them debate each
other like people don't already know who
they're going to vote for right
you could literally
you know you could [ __ ] put a goddamn
I don't know what you could put a
chimpanzee in a blue tie with dementia
and Liberals are going to vote for it
right and then you could take a [ __ ]
horse's ass not even the rest of the
horse and just put a red tie around it I
like I like that [ __ ] horse's ass
makes a lot of [ __ ] sense
I like the chimpanzee that can't
remember
how to open a banana
do you open a banana
listen guy I'm just a simple guy sitting
in a hotel room out here Madison
Wisconsin watching a football game
losing my goddamn money
um
I did see a good political ad where they
the the guy was [ __ ] on the other
guy standing out in the field was
[ __ ] on the other guy saying he's an
environmental activist and I'm thinking
like is that is that bad
my opponent wants clean drinking water
I mean what next Vladimir Putin is there
being being my [ __ ] Barn
I blame this backlash on liberals I
blame it all on them and they're [ __ ]
award shows and wagging their dumb
fingers at people
telling people what they should be they
should be doing when they're so [ __ ]
elitist they they won't even look at 45
of the 50 states
I just fly over those you know it's just
like you know I can't
there's not enough Pilates studios in
Nebraska so like forget that
and then you got all the dumb
conservatives they're out there in
[ __ ] Hollywood [ __ ] a placenta and
the goddamn infinity pools
um so Bill what's your solution I have
none
but I would love to see Bernie Sanders
I just just something about that he
looks like he runs his own like you know
those guys that Fix watches
foreign
they got the glasses on with the
magnifying thing and he just looks up
man I'll do that right they fix it right
there for you like how much they're like
five bucks
they're like what [ __ ] Century do you
live in that you're still there's a guy
that fixes watches in my neighborhood
he's like to
you fix any watch I bring in he he fixes
it right when I'm standing there and he
always goes five bucks I still give him
a 20.
oh what are you the hero of this story
bill I think I was uh speaking of bills
last Thursday if you missed it I had
Bill Maher on my podcast and I cannot
tell you how much I enjoyed having him
as a guest
on my show I had so much fun with that
guy
um so check it out
getting a lot of great feedback and um
yeah it was quite the thrill
to have him on all these years watching
him from Politically Incorrect to real
time
um oh Jesus Christ pick up the [ __ ]
ball you
at least they held him to three points
is that the same guy that's not the same
guy tell me that's not the same guy
you know what I think the Rams did
this is what you do yeah Tom Brady's
winking he knows what's going on
they went to those titty bars last night
didn't they Tommy
he probably set him up with some [ __ ]
titty bar Tampa dollars
sent him down to [ __ ] clear water
how smart is Gronkowski retiring while
he's still young
still in shape crushing into these
commercials fantastic anyways let's talk
some more Sports here people let's not
talk Paul attacks
um
I was so excited
to see uh Tennessee versus Georgia
you know and I was bummed that I was
going to miss LSU Alabama because I was
going to be on stage
right granted I was on stage in Chicago
so I mean that's [ __ ] incredible that
alone is incredible so
but they didn't have the game on in the
green room and uh
but I got to see all of Tennessee
Georgia and I was so [ __ ] excited I'm
like oh man this is going to be some
[ __ ] sec
this is going to be some excitement
they're going to be swapping paint this
is going to be [ __ ] great
Hyatt who I kept calling Hilton I knew
he's named after a hotel
Hilton hooker I mean it just all sounded
like a filthy politician so I'm like
they're gonna they're not gonna be able
to cover these kits I mean they
absolutely [ __ ]
dominated when they played I know oh
they were just running by [ __ ]
Alabama that's Alabama
and them Georgia Bulldogs
all right they were sitting there in
that kennel Tennessee came in and got
their [ __ ] asses whipped
by a bunch of goddamn dogs I mean they
kicked the [ __ ] it wasn't even a [ __ ]
game ever
they just shut them down I think they
would play in manned defense
absolutely shut them the [ __ ] down so
this is what uh so what does that mean
does that mean Alabama stinks
does that mean Tennessee just had a good
day
does that mean George is the number one
[ __ ] team in the country absolutely
it does
because my LSU Tigers who have fallen
off the last couple of years have been
too goddamn busy
Alabama the dream Ends Tonight remember
that [ __ ]
they came in
they didn't come in Alabama went into
Death Valley
and uh unbelievable classic [ __ ] game
obviously could have gone one way or the
other I caught the overtime Alabama goes
down and scores a touchdown because
they're [ __ ] Alabama and then LSU are
they going to answer they go down they
score a touchdown and then they're going
to go for two points
and you know me I'm old school I'm like
what in the [ __ ] are you doing
why the [ __ ] would you do that [ __ ] and
they actually
they actually scored the two-point
conversion and won the goddamn game
and I like what Saban said afterwards he
said nobody's more upset than these kids
in the locker room he does try to
protect those kids
I do like that I buy into it all right
um so congratulations to LSU when was
the last time you saw Alabama with two
losses during the regular season you
know what that means that is opening the
door for boring ass Ohio State to make
it into the playoffs again if they beat
Michigan
and then get their [ __ ] asses kicked
like they always do when they go to the
playoffs
[Laughter]
I'm just [ __ ] with the Ohio State I
don't know anything about you this year
I just like you know I like talking [ __ ]
okay
all right sue me I like to have a good
time on my podcast it's my podcast I can
talk about what I want
I'll tell you what [ __ ] pissed me off
earlier today my dumb ass I thought I
bet on the Packers
I didn't and I'm watching them
okay they go down to the goddamn goal
line
they don't you know
they catch whatever they Aaron throws a
pass this guy might have been passing
interference looks like he puts the
[ __ ] corner back down look better in
the replay that maybe he didn't he
zigzag zigzags down Dives in the end
zone with his knees down he's on the
[ __ ] one yard line right they got
three plays to put it in they can't put
it in
it's the first [ __ ] quarter you lost
four games in a [ __ ] row kick the
goddamn field goal
what do they do they [ __ ] go for it
end up throwing an interception and they
get nothing they get no [ __ ] points
and now they're feeling like [ __ ] and
the lines are feeling great right
I don't understand
this analytic [ __ ] like how long are
these [ __ ] jocks gonna listen to the
[ __ ] math team
you know and I know what all you [ __ ]
youngsters are saying you guys are all
saying well Bill the final score was
15-9 so it didn't matter they do that
[ __ ] it's like it does matter
it does matter because it changes the
entire energy of the game to have a team
down there first and goal on on the one
yard line it's a little bit of a moral
Victory even if you just get a field
goal but when you come back out with a
turnover and nothing
that just gives the other team a [ __ ]
lift I think it is the stupidest [ __ ] in
the [ __ ] world it's the first quarter
get some points on the [ __ ] board
you throw a [ __ ] pick and then the
defense goes out there like ah Jesus
Christ
and we go again you know it's still tied
and the lions are like I can't believe
we're still in this
are we even a franchise
I mean we we literally have not won any
title whatsoever since the Korean
conflict
I don't know
it's just [ __ ] it's it's just
unforgivable if you ask me
unforgivable like oh there's a flag
laying there please tell me that's a
holding call on a defense the receiver
something you ever just know you're
going to lose a bet in the first quarter
I can already feel it like the tone has
been set offsides defense I love it
repeat second down why is he got a
Band-Aid around his [ __ ]
a rubber band I guess that's the string
for his whistle
foreign
blowing that [ __ ] thing
you know
if I was an official I would I would
have that whistle around my neck even
when I came home to my wife
the second she started giving me [ __ ]
I'd [ __ ]
blow the whistle I come up with some
sort of [ __ ]
[Music]
some sort of penalty
personal foul tell me what you think
um
the [ __ ] Patriots won
the Bruins keep on winning
oh
congratulations to the Houston [ __ ]
uh winning their first legitimate World
Series while getting credit for two God
bless you I'm happy for Dusty Baker I am
happy for Dusty Baker but it really
[ __ ] annoyed the [ __ ] out of me
I don't give a [ __ ] that they cheated I
just annoys me that they don't get any
[ __ ] for it and they finally figured
[ __ ] brought it up to Dusty after the
whole series he's like oh the rest of
the world flag
it's like the rest world isn't talking
about there was a [ __ ] gag order on
it that was my problem all right for all
you guys who got confused going I
thought you said you didn't care
it's like yeah I did I don't care I
don't care that you did it what bugs me
is that you didn't get [ __ ] for it you
know and then I ran into one smug
[ __ ] Houston Astros fan who just
smiled through all ago everybody does it
everybody no everybody doesn't put a
camera in the [ __ ] Outfield and wire
up their [ __ ] players and bang on a
trash can they don't they simply don't
and speaking of trash cans I have a
[ __ ] conspiracy theory for you
I think Home Depot causes the hurricanes
in Florida
it's going to put that out there
because once the water goes back out you
know
and you see what's left
where do you go you got to go to Home
Depot and you got to [ __ ] rebuild
and I got all that drywall in there let
me ask you a question all of these
[ __ ] people
all of these [ __ ] poor people in
these goddamn I don't mean they're poor
they don't have any money
this is empathy
all right
which is really difficult for someone
who lives in Hollywood
I mean it's a red State I'd prefer to
fly over Florida
no I love Florida
um
anyway
these poor people they [ __ ] lose
everything everything they have in the
house gets [ __ ] washed down the
street
okay Home Depot is in the same [ __ ]
towns and the next day they're [ __ ]
open and none of their supplies get wet
and you explain that to me
you know
you're telling me the water can't get
through those [ __ ] electronic double
doors
I don't buy it I think they're [ __ ]
with the weather there you go run with
that one post that one
on the internet listen I'm just a simple
guy I'm trying to figure out why these
hurricanes
you know
why do hurricanes only attack the red
States why is that not because of the
[ __ ] liberals
um
all right why does La catch on fire
because you're devils
um
sorry I had a milkshake I might be a
little hopped up on sugar here so please
forgive me for a lot of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] that I'm talking this week
um let's do a couple of reads here
for the week
oh first I gotta tell you my new plan
this is my new plan for all uh
Oh Billy habitual
is uh every month I'm gonna do what I
did did you did the [ __ ] Carolina no
they didn't come back and [ __ ] cover
10-7 Seattle Sneaky Pete oh
Pete what you got up your sleeve cover
um
what was I gonna say uh
oh so this is my new thing every month
I'm gonna go do a 10-day cleanse
where I just don't do [ __ ] for 10 days I
don't have coffee I don't have cigars
sodas
nothing
they don't take a hit of weed none of
that [ __ ] just so nothing gets a hold of
me
right I'll eat right and all of that
type of [ __ ] you just go 10 days and
then the other [ __ ] 20 days I can do
whatever the [ __ ] I want but that's fine
because it'll take a minute for me to
get ramped up again
you know oh I like this I like this play
going nowhere I love this play going
nowhere that was [ __ ] great
hey you know Cooper Cup's one of the
best wide receivers
in the league you know what we should do
hand it off to him like he's a running
back let's see let's see how that works
I think Home Depot fixed this [ __ ]
game too who's this number 45 he's
always great I always forget his name
white all right
anyway so that's that's my game plan
what do you guys think about that and I
just keep going to the gym there you go
you throw it to him exactly exactly
touchdown Cooper cup
thank you no Flags no Flags
no Flags
no Flags there you go
Jesus Christ
what's the name of that [ __ ] coach
Ryan Seacrest
he's just too young and good looking to
be a coach just doesn't make any sense
there you go oh I love that replay a
little stiff arm
and a touchdown
maybe handing it off to him was the
misdirection that they needed
yeah Bill considering you've never
coached on any level why don't you shut
your freckled face there all right let's
do uh
let's do a little uh let's do a little
advertising here shall we
oh look who it is everybody it's all zip
Fred grew up
all right zip recruiter are you hiring
what type of role are you hiring for I
just want to find a simple guide it just
tells me the way and we have from two
plus two to four uh maybe you need to
hire someone to wear many hats
which can be challenging uh or you might
have a simple position to fill
to fill uh but it's taking forever to
find someone who's a great fit for your
company whether you need to hire a civil
engineer
uh in New York
a pediatric nurse in Nebraska an
attorney in Colorado or even a mascot in
Missouri
that's sort of disrespectful huh what do
you think you guys are just screwing
around out there oh zip yeah that can
help you find qualified candidates fast
and now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
from accountants to zoologists and
everything in between zip yeah
uh is matching techno match ship
recruiters matching technology
finds people with the right experience
for your job and presents them to you
then you can invite your top choices to
apply it's so effective that four out of
five
employers who post on zip or
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day try it now for free at
this exclusive web address
recruiter you like that little red
little blue.com slash Burr once again
that's Zip
recruiter.com
ziprecruiter.com Zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire
God damn it I love I love that pause
that just makes me feel like a
broadcaster
um
all right stamps.com right now
seasonal excitement or dread
uh is really starting to settle in
especially for small businesses slaying
through traffic to the post office inbox
more like a blizzard than a winter
wonderland rushing to send cards and
gifts to your loyal clients it's not too
late to get your holiday mailing and
shipping under control with stamps.com
sign up now and you'll be printing your
own postage in minutes stamps.com is
your One-Stop shop for all your shopping
shipping and mailing needs for more than
20 years stamps.com has been
indispensable for over one million
businesses get access to the USPS and
UPS Services you need for your business
to run your business right from your
computer uh no lines no traffic no
hassle man no hassle man stress-free
solution for every small business
usestamps.com to print postage wherever
you need business wherever you do
business sorry all you need is a
computer or a printer and if you need a
package pickup you can easily schedule
through a stamps.com through your
stamps.com dashboard this holiday season
trade late nights and for silent nights
and get started with stamps.com today
sign up give me it's amazing
you get you you buy his [ __ ] it comes to
your gift wrap and then you [ __ ] you
just put a postage on it you give it to
the lady oh the man that comes by sign
up with promo code Burr for a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a free digital
scale
no long-term contracts or commitments uh
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the of the page
and enter Burr b-u-r-r
all right
okay here's a part of the podcast I am
going to give it up to the Astros it was
an amazing run and the fact that you got
caught cheating and you lost like
[ __ ] 10 draft picks and all that and
you still came in strong like that I
gotta tip my cap to you all right for
this one
I'll give it to you and I love Dusty
Baker there I said it and uh I also have
um
a newfound respect for uh not Bradley
Cooper what the [ __ ] his name Baker
Mayfield what's the guy with the B Bryce
Harper
um
that [ __ ] guy's a gamer and he's a
leader and all this [ __ ] that people
have said about him he's a guy he gets a
lot of [ __ ] that [ __ ] guy's the man
um
anyway
so there you go congratulations Houston
all right okay coffee addict
oh here we go
here we go I'm not a coffee addict
anymore I have it under control
um
oh Jesus I just [ __ ] moved this
around where the hell did it go here
there you go that's what I'm talking
about Donald getting in the backfield
um
all right coffee addict dear Billy big
brains long time listener thank you for
all the uh the great free content well
thank you for listening
you know and thank all you guys too this
has been like the sickest tour I've ever
been on
in my life the venues that I've been
able to play
like last night in Peoria Illinois if
you I wish you guys could have gone to
that show
the level that I was [ __ ] teasing
those people it was at 35 32 to the
[ __ ] dolphins not covered God damn it
[ __ ] how does Vegas know
was it three and a half
that drives me up the [ __ ] how about the
Jets how about the [ __ ] Jets
beating the bills and how about my
dumbass not betting on the Jets because
that's one of my theories that I don't
give a [ __ ] how good a team is and how
bad the other team is the Jets are good
this year really good
um
I don't give a [ __ ] what it is so it's
division rivalry games are always close
so if there's a knife as if it's got a
good spread you take the underdog and I
didn't do it uh anyway but I wish you
guys could have been in that show last
night in Peoria Illinois the [ __ ] I was
saying and the amount that I was teasing
them acting like they were all farmers
and they were so [ __ ] cool they
totally rolled with it and laughed you
know I kept [ __ ] with them going I
know you guys
I yeah I know you guys seen a lot of you
guys like build [ __ ] apps and [ __ ]
but I just kept acting like they were
all living out in a farmhouse by
themselves
you know and some of them were like
serial killers
and we played in this old like
old school like hockey Barn
just the shape just the sh the way they
used to
make the Contour like the seats like it
was on on either end they were like
lower and then when you went like Center
Ice stuff it went all the way up like a
wave and then like the final row on on
the top of either side would have like
four seats and then all the way down
would have like you know like 50. like
those really cool sort of 70s looking
thing I would love to come back and go
to a game and they had like they had a
banner up there for 1957 the NIT
Champions and I'm thinking my God the
people that must have played in this
building
over the years and then my dumb ass gets
to go out there
and uh
tell my [ __ ] jokes you know
I was in Chicago I played I played uh
the United Center
[ __ ] looking up at the Blackhawks
Stanley Cup banners when I'm on stage
talking about my dick it doesn't make
any sense
um
fans are crazy good there
um
a lot of these places though I really do
miss
doing a couple of nights there
um because there's so many places like
especially Chicago I've been in like a
zillion times
so there's all these food spots that I
love to eat
um at
I got a great Italian sandwich and they
totally hooked me up with the cannoli
um
I gotta get you I'm gonna get you the
name of that place on the next podcast I
got to give them a shout out I just
don't have it
it's one of the you know Giovanni's or
some [ __ ] like that
um
but they were totally cool
um Mom and Pop type of place right on
the corner across some like the Nobu
Hotel
whatever that place is I'm going to find
out the name you know what [ __ ] this I'm
gonna find out the name right now
all right they were nice enough to give
me not one not two but three free
cannolis and it just so happened
you know that I was [ __ ]
traveling
with Nate Craig and club soda Kenny
let me see if this is gonna work I'm
recording right now on my phone so
they're not gonna let me not gonna let
me do it
let's see here Nobu Hotel
the Nobu Hotel
it's a [ __ ] great hotel but it's like
one of those things you just cannot find
a [ __ ] light switch to save your life
to save your [ __ ] life oh
there it is
there it is shout out
to JP
Graziano
Graziano hooking me up with an
absolutely delicious Italian sandwich
and that one not two but three cannolis
they gave me a t-shirt the whole thing I
I stand by these guys they're on uh West
Randolph Street in North PR Peoria
street diagonally across from the Nobu
Hotel
um old school family run
family run fight the lady behind the
cash register was the mom and the
daughter was getting married
and she goes you look like Bill Burr I
said I have Bill Burr she's like oh my
God can I give you a hug that's what she
said she didn't want a picture she gave
me a hug and they gave me three cannolis
come on
make sure you go by that place good
people
um and then I like the guy behind the
counter he called me guy like 15 times
what do you want guy
um and before that I was in Grand Rapids
I had a great time there it's just been
an amazing run around the country
tonight I'm in Madison Wisconsin so
thank you to everybody who's been coming
up there there you go
all right
it's me with my comedy hat and and there
all right long time listener thank you
for all the great free content uh have
you ever thought about having just six
ounces of coffee instead of three
[ __ ] espressos each time you reach
for the stuff
laughs
well what I like about the espresso
two things I like about the espresso
is
there's like no calories in it according
to the one place I Googled
and then also what I like about the
espresso is you cannot hide behind
whether you know how to make a cup of
coffee or not if you could make an
espresso have that flavor
and not taste all burnt like they do it
like Starbucks
then you know that to me that's that's
the Margarita Pizza I go to a new place
for a pizza I always order a plain like
a margarita or whatever because you
can't hide behind your topics all right
so that's why I do that I get to double
because it's just gone too quick
um
okay anyway but this person says but
seriously think about it all right dot
dot dot little ellipses gives me a
chance to think about it it's just six
ounces of standard
Wawa coffee there's about a hundred
milligrams of caffeine Neuroscience
agrees that this is the correct dose
when you are trying to stay alert
without negative signups side effects I
didn't realize that in medicine this
concept is called the minimal effective
dose
all right you know what
you're you're talking about neuroscience
and then you just said in medicine so
I'm guessing that you're in
this uh you're in this world
so
I I listen to doctors I'm weird that's
what I do I love vaccines by the way
I just got the shingles one I feel great
I don't have a problem with anybody with
authority you know there's a tracking
device in me now I mean I love it
um I am just tapped into the [ __ ]
Matrix
um
anyways which is the goal when
medicating with anything is to have the
minimum effective dose yeah because you
[ __ ] don't want to cure nothing
do you you want us to keep coming back
and get our fix
um
anyway
you [ __ ] [ __ ] suckers I'm anyway I'm
not a doctor oh Jesus but why are you
talking like one
this has helped me
dude I got to tell you something man if
you're like Leonardo Dicaprio and catch
me if you can
said in medicine this concept is called
the minimal effective dose did you just
memorize that so you could be that
douche at a cocktail party
I'm just jealous because you sounded
like a doctor when I was I'm embarrassed
I believed I thought you were anyway I'm
not a doctor but this has helped me
along with decaf still maintaining a
nice morning jolt without feeling like a
piece of [ __ ] oh and in the end he he
ends up being a good [ __ ]
you know trying to help me out
um how about this how about I just have
one cup every week and I drink whatever
the [ __ ] I want
and then I actually learn how to have
like some sort of
um
control
like I kind of you know ideally
I would feel like on a day when I don't
have to work and I got a good night's
sleep or whatever
you know I could get up on like a Sunday
morning
take my kids out to breakfast hold my
wife's hand you know
have a nice morning then just sit down
you know after I play with my kids and
they're going down for their naps or
whatever I could just sit down and have
a nice cup of coffee
and if I did that once a week I I think
that would be all right all right
you know but I appreciate you trying to
help me out because I'm I'm old Billy on
or off that's my deal and I'd like to be
like
Oh Billy responsible
oh oh Billy I think I've had enough you
know
time to go home freckles
all right dating and but I'll take your
advice there um
in just a six ounce six ounces of
standard Wawa coffee there's about 100
milligrams of caffeine
six ounces she's a pony size
I do like the cappuccinos because a lot
of them they don't look like they're
more than six ounces but it is a double
espresso shot in there with the milk
I don't know man
listen I don't drink anymore
I don't [ __ ] with weed that much
occasionally you know
or whatever
you know I don't know
I'm bored man
but I gotta tell you though I [ __ ]
you know when I just took myself off of
everything I was sleeping like a baby
because and then I figured out yeah
that's because a baby doesn't smoke a
cigar and have a double espresso that's
why they're [ __ ] sleeping
everybody thinks it's because they're
tired and they're growing so much that's
not the truth they're just not addicted
to anything yet
other than ruining your night's sleep
um all right dating and in debt
oh brother you just described most of
the people in this country
dude these [ __ ] Banker [ __ ]
they literally have people choosing gas
prices over the environment because
everybody if gas prices goes too high
the amount of people that are
immediately underwater because the price
of everything goes up
it's so [ __ ] ridiculous and the only
reason why the price of gas goes up is
because those [ __ ] stop producing it
not because there isn't enough
there's so many things like that like
you know for half a second you know my
wife started taking me to museums I
don't think about that for a second
you want to talk about somebody climbing
the walls that's actually not true I
actually
really gained an appreciation
for a lot of that [ __ ] that I just
thought was [ __ ] you know
like
I still like pictures of [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] that I recognize as opposed to some
somebody's
acid-fueled collage board or whatever
dream board you know
but anyway
um
I completely forgot what the [ __ ] I was
talking about the [ __ ] was I talking
about
I don't know who gives a [ __ ] it's
probably nothing something about
politics wasn't it
it's about Banks
what was I talking about [ __ ]
NIT Championships uh dating and oh oh
that's right
people just being like [ __ ] oh the
art world there's like I guess like five
families I'm just gonna say five and
they like control the prices
you know what I think they actually do I
think they buy works from unknown
artists and then they kill them
that's what they do and then they say
this guy's the [ __ ] and then they own it
and then they [ __ ] sell it to all of
these people
um I think somehow Home Depot's
bankrolling them right
um
did you hear they put the vaccine in
Starbucks coffee I'm [ __ ] with you
all right dating and in debt uh dear
billiam I saw that credit card debt in
the United States broke a new all-time
high record at 930 million
ish that's what the person says I'm kind
of psyched it's under a billion
you know what would be [ __ ] amazing
is we all just helped each other out
you know
it's like winning the lottery and people
get you out of credit card debt but the
problem is people would immediately get
back in it
so you'd have to like it's all like
education you gotta
get people
you know
you can't just give somebody [ __ ]
money
because they you know most people I
think they're going to get into more
debt with it
that's brutal I remember having brutal
credit card debt
um
and just being behind it and I was just
paying interest and doing all of that
this is my warehouse days
and driving my old truck and I had a car
payment and all of that [ __ ] and I just
remember I was still like living at home
and I still got just sucked at money
and um
fortunately had somebody like break it
down for me
and really helped me out and then when I
started doing stand-up
I started making money and I got to the
point
where I was making as much money as a
comedian as I was making in my day job
and I kept my day job
um
and I just look at that [ __ ] lunatic
Jesus Christ
was that guy the Tampa Bay rhino
that was terrifying 801 left in the
second quarter if you're watching this
um
all right so uh
yeah and then what I did was I just I
paid down
I paid down my credit cards
and then I paid off my student loans and
I just kept working and working and then
I built up
a nest egg because I knew I was moving
to New York City
and I was anticipating that I'd have to
get a job and I just didn't want to go
down there with like nothing
I mean I essentially did I didn't own
anything
but um
the [ __ ] was that guy thrown into like
three goddamn Buccaneers for
anyway
that's brutal man and people have to
live like that and then that causes them
that's terrible these [ __ ] Banker
[ __ ] also according to the article 22
percent of Millennials are going into
debt trying to date
that's what does that mean I can see
this happening it costs a hundred
dollars to go out for sushi and drinks
and most Millennials don't make much
money because they don't work
or they chased shitty dreams while not
sacrificing anything for it now see that
right there is when you're blaming
victims
it's just like what do you like they're
a victim of the [ __ ] no why doesn't
anybody look at the [ __ ] bankers
for putting people into these goddamn
situations what about the way
corporations overwork and underpay
people
what about that
you know what I mean
what about that I've been paying into
Social Security my entire adult life and
now these [ __ ] are going to come in
here and just take it away from me okay
great when there's no social security
can I have my [ __ ] money back
that I paid into it that you were taking
out of my [ __ ] check
that's unreal
um
you know and I noticed that too like
after the pandemic they go people don't
want to work it's like or they don't
want to work the way that they were
working
maybe if they were getting [ __ ]
treated like human beings instead of
like [ __ ] animals they'd be a little
more excited
to leave their house
um these [ __ ] [ __ ] have us all
running on the wheels and then we just
like blame each other man it's stupid
we need some solidarity man
um anyway I know that I know this
because I am one I am one oh this guy's
[ __ ] on Millennials I know this
because I am one jeez I'm all for two
here it's like my [ __ ] football picks
the last guy I thought was a doctor
he wasn't one this person I thought
wasn't a millennial turns out they are
Oh Billy left turn when he should have
gone right there
um I know this because I am one and I
pursued the Arts as a means of income
and watched lots of them try and live
the lifestyle without having done [ __ ]
or earned any money
uh is there anything sadder than the guy
who flexes when he has nothing
yeah I mean that's that that's just
stupid
okay I'll give you that
I'll give you that I didn't know that's
the direction you were going in in on it
okay all right
I still believe that [ __ ] about Banks
but that doesn't apply if you're going
out and you're just lighting up your
card you're trying to I mean what are
you attracting to
you know you gotta you know
just be who you are just say listen I'd
like to take out for a cup of coffee I'm
swimming in credit card debt and I need
to figure out how to get out of this
[ __ ] okay
and when the red bottom shoes [ __ ]
walks away from you just just know that
that saved you
hundreds of millions of dollars
anyways reminded me of the stories you
and your generation of comics tell about
being broke and roughing it on a futon I
almost never see that
yeah well you know in defense of you
guys there wasn't any Instagram and
everybody acting like they had a whole
bunch of money and presenting most of
them presenting a lie
of how much stuff they have
or what they actually look like the
shape that they're in
you know like
or even just the lie that having a bunch
of stuff is going to make you happy
um
anyway I almost never see that he said
when I started an art I saw kids young
people blow through money they didn't
have to keep up appearances I found my
place in it all and I do very well now I
drove a hand-me-down car and never
upgraded my phone unless I needed to
smart man
uh those plus a million other small
sacrifices and I'm doing okay enough to
not have to worry about the cost of
dating uh um I want to feel bad
for ones that are struggling but it's
like
your take on those
fat people losing weight shows
uh they enjoyed eight or so years of
having anything they wanted and now
they're crying because it didn't work
out
insert a soap's Fable I don't know what
that means
all right let's get to the next one here
um
all right wife says you repeat yourself
oh yeah I wouldn't argue with that
dear Bill Gazette I watch you on all
your appearances and listen to all your
podcasts I enjoy hearing you make your
points to different people and hearing
their reactions my wife says you repeat
yourself a lot she knows nothing about
sports but seems to know all about
deflategate NFL championships and now
the Astros yeah because I'm trying to
get that out there I was wondering if
you get that a lot or if my wife is just
being annoying does NIA ever complain
about this
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh my God if you guys could hear how if
you think my wife is funny on this
podcast when I'm off the podcast
she is [ __ ] hilarious she absolutely
destroys me
she was doing an impression of me the
other night
then after a while I just stopped
laughing I was just looking at her like
how beautiful she is and how [ __ ]
Talent she don't even know how [ __ ]
funny she is
sometimes
she's [ __ ] hilarious absolutely my
wife gives me [ __ ] in a loving funny way
about everything that I do yeah she's
always saying I never shut up
she would she would [ __ ] high-five
your wife
and your wife is right she's not being
annoying I do repeat myself a lot you
know I don't read a lot I don't have a
lot to say but I got a lot of time to
cover so yes anyway P.S after writing
the above I read some comments on
YouTube and she might not be the only
one
um yeah I mean yeah that's what I do
and I'll keep doing it all right with
your passive aggressive
thing like you know hey I'm not saying
it my wife's saying it
and then but then I read some YouTube
comments this is I gotta be honest with
you this is a classic internet [ __ ]
thing to do is to go out and be like oh
there's something negative about
somebody who's doing well let me see if
I can get some facts about it
air quote facts yeah well keep reading
YouTube comments I don't give a [ __ ] and
I'll keep repeating myself all right
hacky campaigns
yo Billy on the hilly
uh by the way I don't have a problem
with your wife your wife's funny you
you're a [ __ ] you're a little sideways
[ __ ]
you lay in the weeds I didn't like that
I didn't like the PS I liked everything
until the PS right when you sneakily try
to put your balls on the table for half
a second [ __ ] knock that down there
you go
all right hacky campaigns yo Billy on
the hilly
all politics aside the mailers said it
that go out during election seasons are
pathetic I know
uh yeah can they talk down to you
anymore like how dumb do they think
liberals and consumer and conservatives
are the average person I should say
first off I hate getting all that mail I
know kills a bunch of trees and it
doesn't sway you one way or the other I
think maybe like with the questions
like vote no on [ __ ] 26
like trying to figure out what's going
miss this [ __ ] field goal message you
son of a [ __ ] hook hook Push It Wide
push it what and it's blocked
oh huge [ __ ] huge
oh that's demoralizing
that'll that'll put a [ __ ]
that'll put a fly in the ointment right
there I love it uh first off I hate
getting all that mail second if I try
and read anything it makes me lose my
mind specifically one guy whose name I
won't use but here's his shtick
he has a woman's name
okay it's Jackie something or other
uh flat out it's a woman's name all
right so it's not Jackie or Terry
said Priscilla
um I'm not talking about one that goes
both ways I'm talking about a name
you've never heard a guy have uh Julie
um up to you if you want to read it on
air his name is nine up because I don't
I don't want to get into the politics I
I I
go over either side
and I go at the bankers and I don't even
know if I'm right but that feels better
to do
that'd just be some douche
blaming that you know red or blue going
deep nothing there the [ __ ] was that
that's good that keeps the cornerbacks
honest they'll throw it underneath
maybe throws it underneath I don't know
I don't know what the purpose of that
was anyway but here's the kicker
Not only would someone go oh I'll vote
for a lady for a change
wait a minute let's see wait let me go I
missed something here
Adam I can read it on there he said and
he purposely puts women on the front of
all his mailers
yeah this guy's a genius
this guy's a genius he's he's not he's
staring in
I mean if he's a conservative this is
like suicidal
but if he's a liberal I mean yeah yeah
everyone's going to think that he cares
anyway but here's the kicker Not only
would someone go oh I'll vote for a lady
for a change
uh he has his wife who happens to be
black front and center on the mailers so
now it becomes oh I'll Vote for This
candidate who can bring some diversity
yep nope it's just a Dopey white guy who
knows people won't completely unfold the
mailer before trashing it and thinks it
it's his wife running for office and her
name is his looking forward to your next
special
uh Nia hits the stage
um
oh I get it I sent her out there instead
of me so I can be the woke comedian
um I hate that even I shouldn't be
saying that
white people should not be using the
term woke unless they actually know what
the [ __ ] it means and then they wouldn't
use it rather than taking it and then
making it mean something else here's one
for me repeating again there's literally
a [ __ ] YouTube video out there that
is a collection it says a collection of
Karen's Karen's used to be
it was a white woman making up a lie
okay
coming up with some [ __ ] saying it
about a black person and they either end
up dead or in jail now once white people
got a hold of it
you know when white women started
calling other white women's Karen's you
know
just so they wouldn't be labeled as one
because they're using the term it now
just became
like it's just women screaming upset
about you know in like a [ __ ]
a convenience store and I'm watching the
compilation in in the compilation of
Karen's they had a black woman
and then it just completely changes the
the meaning of it
and the point behind all of it well you
could have learned something
you know learn about an injustice now it
just becomes just Bland horseshit
um anyway I'm off my [ __ ] soapbox
um what the [ __ ] was I reading about
here
why did everything just go away
probably because you were preaching Bill
all right well there you go
um
anyway plowing ahead here
um yeah tonight's the last night on this
run
and then I uh end up back in LA and all
I have left people I just have on this
tour I just have
three more road trips three three and
three I got nine more shows left after
tonight I'm into the single digits
uh biggest tour I've ever done
the most fun I've had I'm not gonna lie
to you it was a little
you know freaking me out
you know in the beginning and then with
uh that Boston gig hanging over my head
you know
oh well freckles was having a rough one
maybe that's why I was drinking so much
coffee and smoking
um
but uh tell me you guys what do you guys
think about that you know
do it with me every ever the first 10
first 10 days of every month
right
you just shut it down
take stock to see where you're at
right and then whatever your little
vices
I mean as far as the way I work I can
just sort of gradually
get back into it but you know after a
couple of weeks
starts to ramp up again but then oh boy
here's another month
another 10 days off and then I just feel
like nothing ever
gets will get a hold of me
for uh
you know long enough that it's going to
do like damage
does that make any sense like it's like
how about like eating like [ __ ] because
I'm kind of including that too
like say what you want about going
veggie I mean I [ __ ] it I've run into a
couple people that like are just
vegetarian and they like glowing
you know I will tell you this as much as
people [ __ ] on vegetarians I've never
well that's not true that's not true
it's been a while since I've seen a fat
[ __ ] vegetarian used to see it a lot
because they're like I'm a vegetarian
and they're eating like potato chips but
if you're actually a vegetarian that is
eating vegetables but even then then you
gotta watch out because they spray them
with so many uh
pesticides
I don't know dude you know I I got I got
to start growing my own food oh Jesus
Bill you've been on the road too long
here
um
I really feel like you know just to have
something
just to have something when the [ __ ]
hits the fan
right get myself a couple of grenades
and some guns
you know got some tomatoes and some
[ __ ] pears or whatever
then I'll be all right you know
I don't know
well you know what you do you just keep
living like nothing bad's ever gonna
happen and you get one cyanide pill
right
for everybody you love for like they're
coming up the walk everybody one two see
on the other side
foreign
and you just totally just [ __ ]
buy into everything that they're selling
you on TV
right
the food the jet ski the Super Bowl
party
[ __ ] everything are they gonna call
past interference there
oh they should yeah they absolutely
should they absolutely should did they
call pass interference they did not
just giving them a [ __ ] chest massage
that was the weirdest pass I've ever
seen at a completion
Tom Brady Tom Brady doing what he does
best go ahead go into the oh they're not
in a preview I don't know what the [ __ ]
they're doing here
Tom Brady watch this
watch this minute 16 left the greatest
to ever do it complete first down big
cushion what is the point of this
what is the [ __ ] point you stopped
him the whole [ __ ] first half
he knows how to use the clock this whole
giving him the middle of the field is
not gonna [ __ ] work you're just
giving them three points here
why the [ __ ] would you do this he's
gonna have three shots at the [ __ ]
End Zone if you keep this up
well thank God that idiot just dropped
the ball
Jesus Christ
does he have the analytics guys in the
field though
that's just a classic play where you you
start running before you got the ball
all you youngsters out there all right
48 seconds left
this is already he's already gotten him
three points ah unless his team [ __ ]
him
unless his team Fox and fournette for a
first down did somebody jump off side so
we got we got a false start Tom's
walking forward he's walking forward
Tom's walking forward Tom's walking back
he wants to inspire change
offsides on the defense
it's declined in a first down great
fantastic
the whole [ __ ] first whole [ __ ]
first half
Ryan Seacrest no [ __ ] clue what he's
doing
don't give a [ __ ] if he has a ring in 28
shows
letter fournette in the backfield Tom
Brady back to pass dumps it off to
fournette there's another [ __ ] five
yards four yards 36 seconds
what you're listening to is audio of the
prevent defense once again
preventing you from stopping the offense
who the [ __ ] came up with the prevent
defense
the NFL commissioner
people like offense
they they don't they don't like great
defense they don't want to see a 7-3
game
they don't want to see the Rams cover
at seven to three they want to seam
cover at 37-33 that that's that's what
we're really going for here
oh Jesus Christ everybody chewing on
their [ __ ] mouth guards now because
that guy in the goddamn Warriors
all right what do we got here second and
five
he's literally gonna have a shot at the
end zone here if he completes this
oh thank God these that's nice defense
though
Kendrick thinks he just won the Super
Bowl again
I mean what are these defensive players
so excited about
there he got he got there early he got
there early that was actually past
interference
all right here we go
Tom Brady back to pass Standing Tall in
the pocket going for the end zone and
nothing bit of a waste of play there if
you ask me
number six Still Loving himself Still
Loving himself he probably get stressed
like that in the morning with each
article of clothing he puts on he starts
[ __ ] talking [ __ ]
right well I guess that was third down
I should have gone underneath for the
first that's what I would have done with
my zero Rings you know the guy was seven
rings I think he did it wrong
all right now with the dumb grass the
hurricane was last week buddy just
[ __ ] kicked the [ __ ] ball
I literally for thought for a second
that was Denzel's brother
maybe his nephew
all right he's lining up for a kick once
again the prevent defense [ __ ] you in
the age three points right there now the
Buccaneers are covering great call man
great call you had a four-point [ __ ]
lead now it's down to one point
fantastic hey but they didn't score a
touchdown let's just give them [ __ ]
three points
you know who I play Home Depot I blame
Home Depot all right that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves I'll check in on you on
Thursday